Oh
today I'm excited to talk about our
first content update for the Elder
Scrolls online it's the next piece of
the veteran gameplay pie and it's
specifically designed for groups of four
players and it's got even more special
content designed for groups of 12
players it's the adventure zone known as
crag long
craglorn is different from the other
zones and Elder Scrolls online content
starts at veteran rank 10 and the
exploration content is built for groups
of four it has new and dangerous veteran
rank Group dungeons and it introduces
trials our large group veteran PvE
system
when you first enter craglorn there's
gonna be a mystery that set up the
constellations are missing from the sky
and you're gonna hear rumor of these
beings called Celestials and they are
the warrior the mage the serpent and the
thief and how they're impacting craglorn
and what's going on is going to be what
your group discovers to actually get
introduced to that story
we have quests that are specifically
designed for four-person groups these
quests take you to different locations
throughout craglorn and they keep
revealing more and more of the story but
of course we also have the quests that
come about from natural exploration if
you're out exploring with your group
you'll stumble on these quests many of
which you can repeat on a daily basis
but it's the main story quests that
really Drive you to these larger places
of interest that are specifically
tailored to reveal more of the overall
story of craglorn just like normal zones
craglorn has a main city and that cities
called Belle Qarth which might be a
great staging area for you to set up a
group then as you and your group go out
and explore the world you'll see what we
called Dells you may have experienced
Dells in the Overland content for
instance 8:00 or dawn or any of the
other normal zones the great things
about delves in Cranbourne is their
instance to your party
they're gonna have a sky shard in them
which gives you those all-important
skill points and they're also gonna have
boss fights in them so it's almost like
a mini dungeon set up for just your
group in craglorn the places of interest
you find are very reminiscent of our
veteran dungeons they're instance they
have a high level of difficulty and
these should challenge even the best of
our four-person groups and that brings
us to the brand new large group
challenge that is being introduced in
craglorn trials specifically designed
for groups of 12 trials are really for
the best of the best once you begin
you'll have to overcome a lot of
challenges such as environmental hazards
there's a lot of different monsters we
throw at you and of course there are
boss monsters that have interesting
tactics that you haven't encountered
anywhere in the game before and if all
of the encounters and bosses weren't
enough you have a timer that you're up
against and you also have a limited
number of resurrections that your group
is allowed as you're going through the
trials we're going to be tracking your
time in those resurrections they count
against that time but if your group
turns in one of the best times you're
going to be added to the lead
and if you make it to the top of the
leaderboards you're going to get rewards
it's the ultimate challenge for your
group in the Elder Scrolls online that's
just the briefest of overviews of many
of the things that you'll be seeing in
craglorn we had a lot of fun making this
zone and we hope you'll have a lot of
fun playing
you